billion dollar bankruptcies are like
superhero movies at first they were
exciting there were only a few of them
you knew they cost tons of money so you
figured I'll check it out but at this
point we've seen so many it's getting
boring
this is just a bunch of characters I
don't care about with the exact same
plot but every now and then a super
villain emerges so insane so disgusting
that they pull me back in I'm talking of
course about the CEO of Celsius Alex
machinski and his wife Christy machinsky
because as a quick reminder Celsius is a
crypto company that is in bankruptcy
right now with billions of dollars owed
that they do not have so what are they
doing to plug the hole are they hard at
work no they're selling merch merch that
says unbankrupt yourself
that's right folks for 28 you could pay
the people who caused your bankruptcy
literally millions of people have money
locked up in Celsius probably gone
forever because of the machinski's and
the machinski's decision is to sell
merch about it and I know the obvious
reaction to this is that there must be
some mistake they got hacked it's an
accident well no because it turns out
Chrissy machinski got called out for
this and when she did she didn't
apologize she said thank you for
promoting the shirt they're going to
increase t-shirt production because of
this this is so unhinged bankrupting
millions and then selling a shirt that
says unbankrupt yourself this is crazier
than if Taco Bell sold shirts saying
undiarrhea yourself it's like wait a
second you caused this you did this to
me with your Dorito taco thing you
concocted in a lab right you told me
this was food I didn't create this mess
like there's literally no way to
interpret unbankrupt yourself as
anything but taunt the victims of your
plan and what's worse is the background
to all this because remember unbankrupt
yourself isn't just some random saying
it's a modification of their original
catchphrase remember they told everyone
they needed to unbank themselves that's
literally the whole point of Celsius the
idea that Banks were evil and that
Celsius is different because Celsius
isn't a bank which makes it awkward when
Celsius declares bankruptcy so their
motto actually changed from unbank
yourself to unbankrupt yourself who knew
five letters could do so much of the
heavy lifting and I think we have to
acknowledge that this is pretty funny
right uh while also acknowledging the
pain of the people who lost everything
and how horrible this is I mean the
machinski's are just running this whole
thing like a Ringling Brothers Circus so
it is entertaining no matter how serious
it also is the machitzkis are just
Shameless I mean I'm not going to be
surprised if they sell bankruptcy
documents as nfts after all this but if
you thought that was bad it actually
gets worse because like the Dorito Taco
at Taco Bell there are layers to this
Abomination you see recently a secret
call of Celsius got leaked it was in all
hands where Celsius was supposedly going
to unveil the big plan to recover this
whole thing remember I said at the
beginning of this whole debacle that
they should just close up shop Chapter 7
bankruptcy I said it in my first video
about them but Celsius told everyone no
they were going to save the company so
this is the time that they were going to
discuss the big plan the big plant
that's going to change everything and
put Celsius back on the right path so
what is this plan to recover billions of
dollars third chapter is US reopening
our services right so we gave it a code
named Kelvin right absolute zero so
we're planning to be basically we're
planning to reopen with a process that
does not require you to trust us in
anything we literally made a joke about
like Fahrenheit Celsius when we first
heard about this doing wait little did I
know that that's like their business
plan is to try to trick people into
thinking that it's a new company by
renaming it Kelvin I guess they're also
trying to go with this idea that oh this
time will be trustless but that's funny
because only a year ago Alex was saying
their main job was to fight for trust
with customers this is a fight over
trust right who is going to make the
most trust deposits with customers and
who is not going to make any trust
deposits with customers so I guess y'all
are giving up that fight huh like okay
guys you were right we can't be trusted
which is why our new business model is
admitting you can't trust us
like they somehow think the word
absolute zero trust is like going to get
you to trust them again it's such a
strange thing like deposit money with us
because you can't trust us and we're
admitting that not only that it gets
worse when you realize that their big
plan their big scheme is to start a
custody service for crypto one of the
foundational products that we're going
to offer in the future is custody and
the core concept of custody is that
that's your property and we're holding
it on your behalf so your big plan to
save the company and rescue people's
accounts who can't withdraw is to get
more people to deposit
I don't know if that's gonna work out
for you which by the way the person who
leaked this audio someone named Tiffany
Fong is right now being threatened by
the machine skis who aren't happy that
their terrible plans have been leaked
and in another delicious piece of irony
Chrissy machinski wants the person who
leaked it to pay back the creditors
Celsius owes with the AdSense she made
from leaking this video which first of
all the video wasn't monetized that's
for one number two
you're the one who owns the Creditor
like Celsius people not everyone else
everyone else it's not their job to
unbankrupt you this is the amazing thing
is like they think that's everyone
else's job besides them who got everyone
in this mess so let me tell you Christy
machinski you're in the wrong okay this
is so messed up you have to stop selling
these t-shirts you have to pay these
people back and just stop with all this
nonsense about this chapter 11
bankruptcy restructuring where you're
spending tens of millions of dollars a
month on fees and if you're wondering
why I'm addressing Chrissy directly is
it's because in a funny twist of fate
she's actually subscribed she's a
subscriber to coffeezilla